marine rognés et sa nasse naoui ont
poussé les portes de son atelier
lassé du letton à la base c'est du béton
là c'est simplement argenté d'accord
mais c'est de tout ça c'est du béton se
mater des temps après je travaille je
travaille surtout mais tous métaux
bijoux peintures gravures celestino oxo
est un artiste aux multiples facettes
depuis début décembre il présente au
public son savoir faire et ses pièces
uniques dans un lieu insolite un café
transformé en atelier vivant pendant
trois semaines c'est bien et c'est bien
qu'on subissait la portée de tout le
monde sait ça plus à mes yeux c'est très
important tout le monde peut bénéficier
de ce plaisir ce que je j'ai apprécié le
plus ici c'est le contact avec l'artiste
et le voir travailler le voir dans son
atelier et c'est toujours très
intéressant
j'avais pas d'aquarelles j'avais pas de
d'acrylique de l'huile des belles toiles
et j'avais mes petits crayons à papier
après des études à l'école boulle
celestino suit les traces de son père
dans le bâtiment en 2015 un infarctus le
rappel à l'ordre
ce tableau représente cet électrochoc je
me suis dit à quoi je sers dans ce monde
qu'est ce que je fais réellement pour
moi et qu'est ce que je fais pour les
autres et finalement résultats jeudi
n'ont pas grand chose sauf à courir
après de l'argent pour pouvoir se
survivre c'est tout je dis non
aujourd'hui pense à toi pour ça ta
passion et vie de table et said vie de
ta passion
donc sauf que j'ai fait cet adepte des
matériaux de récup veut rendre l'art
accessible à tous les publics mais aussi
aux artistes qui s'ignorent faute de
moyens pour eux celestino a créé
l'association claix art
l'objectif qu'ils vivent de leur passion
en mettant leurs outils en commun